[Musique]
bienvenue pour le 7-8 politique sur tv
60,18 voici le sommaire pour ce mois de
juillet sur les 577 députés élus le 18
juin 2010 7 424 n'avait jamais eu ce
mandat c'est le cas de jean noël barrot
élus de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines sous l'étiquette modem
république en marche deux ans après quel
est son bilan nous allons en parler avec
lui en plateau du côté des républicains
la reconstruction peine toujours à se
mettre en place quelle ligne adoptée en
repli sur le centre une ouverture sur
l'extrême droite est le président du
sénat gérard larcher a tranché depuis
bien longtemps comme en oeuvre utile en
coulisses éléments de réponse au cours
d'un entretien réalisé voici quelques
jours par grégory canal est alors d'un
déplacement des sénateur des yvelines à
toussus le noble et puis avant les
vacances le préfet des yvelines a
répondu aux questions des élus lors de
la dernière séance du conseil
départemental l'occasion de parler à
décentralisation je reçois donc pour
débuter jean-noël barrot bonjour et
bienvenue en plateau par député des
yvelines modem membre de la commission
des finances notamment à l'assemblée et
dans un rapport sur les finances
publiques et a publié le 25 juin les
magistrats de la cour des comptes
elle s'inquiète du coût budgétaire des
annonces post grand débat ils craignent
une dérive du déficit public d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
est-ce qu'ils ont raison de s'inquiéter
alors d'abord ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que cette année pour la deuxième année
consécutive mais c'est une première
historique on peut dire à l'assemblée
nationale nous avons consacré deux
semaines au mois de juin pour examiner
l'exécution des budgets jusqu'à présent
ont passé trois mois de l'année à
l'automne pour discuter des projections
budgétaires ce qu'on allait faire de
l'argent de l'argent public
désormais nous passons de semaine au
mois de juin pour discuter de ce qui a
été fait de l'argent public et si
l'argent public a été utilisé à bon
escient
ça n'existait pas jusqu'à présent
puisque la loi de règlement celle qui
fige l'exécution des comptes été votée
en une journée
et donc si c'est le cas alors justement
est ce que l'argent a bien été utilisé
alors chacun je les députés de la
commission des finances sont chacun
pencher sur un sujet en particulier
j'ai voulu pour ma part examiné dans la
ligne budgétaire qui est celle dont j'ai
la responsabilité asile immigration et
intégration
le coût des de la politique de
reconduite à la frontière et son
efficacité avec à la fois les politiques
de départ forcé et à la fois les
politiques de départ aidé c'est à dire
les incitations financières que l'on
peut donner aux personnes pour qu'elles
rentrent dans leur pays d'origine
c'était la première fois qu on
s'attachait à estimer le coût global de
cette politique publique et donc je
pense que c'était utile
ensuite sur les les questions
macroéconomiques que vous posiez à
l'instant il est vrai que un certain
nombre de gestes qu'ils étaient très
attendues ont été faits en direction des
classes moyennes est en réalité de
l'ensemble des français et qui va
désormais falloir les financer avec des
réductions de dépenses publiques ce qui
a déjà été engagée dans les deux
premières années qui va devoir
s'amplifier
on va revenir dans un instant sur cette
question des expulsions justement parce
que vous avez pointé le coût que cela
pouvait représenter et on va y revenir
au cours de cet entretien tout d'abord
je reviens sur ces question plus globale
sur le budget le gouvernement prévoyait
de rétablir l'équilibré des comptes
publics même de dégager un excédent de
0,3 pour cent du pipe c'était pour 2022
aujourd'hui on évoque plutôt un déficit
de 1,2 pour cent c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui rien ne se passe comme
prévu va écouter la première chose à
dire c'est que depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron la france est enfin
sorti de la procédure pour déficit
excessif
la procédure pour déficit excessif c'est
une procédure que peut déclencher
l'union européenne
quand un de ces états dépassent pendant
trop longtemps le seuil des 3% de
déficit nous sommes sortis de cette
situation et les projections actuelles
et en tenant compte des dépenses et des
réductions d'impôts qui ont fait suite
au mouvement des gilet jaune nous
permettent de penser que nous resterons
à l'abri de cette procédure à laquelle
nous étions soumises et dont nous étions
l'un des seuls pays européens à être
encore les
le sujet donc de ce point de vue là
évidemment on peut regretter que ces
cartes d'une perspective d'un retour à
l'équilibré voire d'un budget en
excédent
mais il nous reste encore trois ans pour
essayer de réduire les dépenses
inefficaces et en tout cas moi c'est ce
à quoi je vais m'employer à la
commission des finances cet automne et
peut-être d'être moins généreux est ce
que le président a été trop généreux
pendant ses deux premières années de
mandat je crois pas qu'ils aient
vraiment eu de la milliards d'euros de
baisses d'impôts oui mais c'est une
réponse forte à une demande forte qui a
été exprimée pendant le grand débat
national pendant le mouvement de gilet
jaune
je crois que les français n'auraient pas
compris que suite à cette grande
mobilisation qui a débuté par une
exaspération liées au pouvoir d'achat
qu'on n'ait pas apporté de réponses en
matière de pouvoir d'achat assez à ses
demandes
et puis à nouveau je le répète il reste
encore et les français le savent parce
que je les ai entendus pendant les
grands débats qui se sont tenus ici dans
les yvelines
il reste encore un certain nombre de
dépenses inefficaces sur lesquels on
peut agir pour essayer de financer ces
réductions d'impôts et puisqu'on parle
des dépenses justement vous l'avez
mentionné tout à l'heure ce rapport
parlementaire pardon sur la politique
d'expulsion des sans-papiers que vous
avez menées en moyenne une expulsion de
force 13800 euros voilà ce que ça coûte
c'est ce que vous dites en comparaison
un retour aidé ses 2500 euros il faut
donc changer de cap et s'orienter vers
des retours aidés alors d'autres
objectifs là n'étaient pas
nécessairement de faire des économies
c'était simplement de faire la
démonstration que là où les
parlementaires qui ont été critiqués
assez fortement pendant le grand débat
national peuvent être utiles c'est quand
ils rendent des comptes aux français sur
la manière dont est utilisé l'argent
public
la politique de reconduite aux
frontières étaient peut évaluer pourquoi
parce qu'elles mobilisent
de très nombreux ministères qui ont
chacun leur comptabilité propre mais
donc quand on regarde une politique
publique qui les mobilise tous ont fini
par ne pas savoir combien il coûte est
donc le premier objectif c'était de
rendre des comptes et le coup les
comptes qui sont rendus à l'occasion de
la remise de ce rapport c'est
qu'effectivement une expulsion coûte 14
mille euros soit 500 millions d'euros au
total c'est à peu près le montant que
nous allons prélever sur les gaffes à
quand un retour aidé coûte 2500 euros
c'est-à-dire l'incitation financière qui
est donnée plus les tous les frais
engagés pour cette procédure scouts
évidemment beaucoup moins cher la
recommandation que nous avons fait
à l'issue de ce rapport c'est elle est
double la première c'est d'engager de
poursuivre les efforts diplomatiques
engagés par la france et l'union
européenne avec les pays d'origine des
personnes concernées puisque si les
expulsions coûtent très chers c'est
parce qu'un grand nombre d'entre elles
n'aboutissent pas et si elles
n'aboutissent pas c'est parfois en
raison de difficultés opérationnelles
mais souvent parce que le pays d'origine
refuse d'accepter le retour de la
personne concernée or on a pu mesurer
dans ce travail que lorsque des accords
de coopération a été signé
les retours se passent de manière
beaucoup plus simple et en matière de
retours aidés là nous avons une
recommandation qui est de monter en
puissance sur ce dispositif parce que
nous sommes en retard par rapport à
d'autres pays européens qu'ils utilisent
beaucoup plus en moyenne que les
expulsions c'est pas le cas en france on
fait plus d'expulsions que de retours
aidés et que pour les pays pour les
ressortissants de pays qui sont assez
lointain je pense notamment aux pays
africains au pays du moyen-orient qui
ont souvent mobilisé des communautés des
financements pour pour parvenir à
arriver en europe un retour est souvent
perçu comme un échec sauf s'il
s'accompagne d'un vrai projet de
réinsertion et c'est ce à quoi cette
aide au retour peut contribuer et ça va
pas créer un appel d'air
justement ça n'a pas créé d'appel drs
que plus de personnes justement
cherchent à regagner le pays qui
pratiquaient les pays qui pratiquent sur
ses retours aidés pour justement en
bénéficier c'est une très bonne question
alors évidemment on a voulu s'en assurer
ce que l'on a fait c'est qu'on a
collecté c'était aussi une manière pour
nous parlementaires de démontrer qu'on
était en capacité de le faire
de très nombreuses données des milliers
de données par nationalités sur les
les comportements d'arrivée est de
retour et nous avons pu mesurer ainsi
que l'aide au retour volontaire le
l'incitation financière avait un
véritable effet déclencheur sur la
décision de rentrer dans son pays
d'origine mais que effectivement quand
on augmente le montant de l'aide au
retour il n'y a pas d'effet sur les
arrivées en réalité les montants
concernés ne sont pas suffisants pour
justifier je dirais le voyage ou le
trajet la prise de risque pour venir en
europe et donc ce n'est pas ce
dispositif date de retour qui est de
nature à créer un appel d'air
si on élargit un petit peu le propos
pour faire un bilan de vos deux
premières années en tant que député
voulait résumeriez comment est-ce
qu'elles ont été intéressants décevante
par rapport à ce que vous pouviez vous
en attendre alors elles ont été
satisfaisantes parce que sur je dirais
deux sujets majeurs pour le territoire
nous avons réussi à faire évoluer les
choses
le premier sujet c'est la question du
logement social et des obligations liées
à la loi sru qui impose aux communes de
plus de 1500 habitants en ile de france
d'atteindre 25 % de logements sociaux à
l'horizon 2025
cette contrainte est plus forte en ile
de france que dans le reste du
territoire français et c'est justifié
parce que créer des logements sociaux
c'est un gendre un certain nombre de
deux coups pour les communes qui sont
plus faciles à absorber quand on est
proche de paris qui a des transports en
commun qui a tout un tas de services
pour accompagner les personnes qui
arrivent mais c'est pas tout à fait le
cas pour les communes des yvelines et de
l'ile-de-france en général qui se
trouvent hors du coeur dans ces
urbanisée de l'île de france
donc ce que nous avons nous avons réussi
à faire adopter c'est un des amendements
que nous avons rédigé en lien avec les
maires de la vallée de chevreuse
notamment c'est que ce seuil de 1500 le
habitants à partir duquel on est
assujettie aux obligations soient
relevés pour les communes qui sont dans
le rural de l'île de france au même
niveau que pour le reste du territoire
ce qui va leur permettre d'aménager et
faire de l'aménagement du territoire qui
soit un petit peu plus harmonieux il ya
eu aussi d'autres avancées que nous
avons pu obtenir dans le cadre de cette
discussion et qui vont permettre là
aussi
2 au maire de d'envisager de penser
l'aménagement du territoire dans de
meilleures conditions
donc ça c'est le premier sujet sur
lequel on a pu avancer c'était l'année
dernière cette année le sujet sur lequel
on a pu avancer et qui est trés
important pour
en tout cas la 2e circonscription des
yvelines c'est la question des nuisances
sonores vallée de chevreuse plus
particulièrement effectivement je leur
précise votre circonscription s'étend de
viroflay à cerner la ville on est sur
des problématiques très différentes mais
cette partie rurale et ont donc on en
revient aux nuisances sonores
vous avez raison et des nuisances
sonores qui existent en valais chevreuse
du fait de la circulation des deux roues
mais des nuisances sonores qui existent
aussi à versailles dans une moindre
mesure à viroflay disons surtout à
versailles en raison de la proximité
d'infrastructures de transport lourdes
je pense à la 86 à versailles et je
pense bien sûr aux infrastructures
ferroviaires et au pont des chantiers à
versailles qui du fait des vibrations
qu'ils engendrent y compris après les
travaux qui ont été menés engendre des
désagréments voire des risques pour la
santé des riverains auquel il fallait
qu'on apporte une réponse ou tout au
moins dont il fallait qu'on puisse tenir
compte désormais dans la loi et il ya
deux avancées sur ces deux problèmes les
deux roues et les infrastructures qui
sont majeurs la première c'est que
désormais dans le code de
l'environnement et créer un chapitre sur
la prévention de la pollution sonore et
qui va avoir des répercussions en chaîne
sur la plupart des décisions
d'aménagement et d'infrastructures qui
seront prises à l'avenir et pour rentrer
plus dans le détail désormais quand on
construira on rénovera qu'on développera
qu on aménagera des infrastructures de
transport on ne devra pas seulement
tenir compte du bruit moyen qui est une
obligation jusqu'à présent mais qui
n'était pas suffisante mais d autres
formes de bruit qui sont plus subtiles
mais plus difficile à mesurer et qui
sont celles dont on sait aujourd'hui
qu'elles ont un impact sur la santé à
savoir les vibrations et ce qu'on
appelle l'émergence c'est à dire les
pics de bruit quand un motard démarre ou
quand un train passe et que ça fait
beaucoup de bruit et puis qu'ensuite il
ya pas beaucoup de bruit quand vous
prenez la moyenne vous pouvez penser que
le bruit et moyens alors que des bruits
très forts peuvent être engendrés et ça
c'est très important
et puis concernant les deux roues nous
avons obtenu un engagement de la
ministre
des transports pour qu'une charte qui
avait déjà été rédigé mais dont nous ne
connaissions pas encore l'existence avec
les constructeurs puissent être signé
sur des engagements de lutte contre la
mise en sonnant la construction même des
véhicules et d'autre part nous avons
obtenu que pendant deux ans puissent se
tenir
une expérimentation de radars acoustique
qui ont vocation à terme à pouvoir
verbaliser les conducteurs de véhicules
qui sont trop brouillons et ça tombe
très bien parce que en parallèle nous
avons travaillé avec bruitparif
l'observatoire du bruit en ile-de-france
pour que la vallée de chevreuse et
notamment les zones très fréquentées par
les motards puisse accueillir l'une des
trois expérimentations de ces de ces
radars acoustique que bruitparif à
développer il y en a une qui sera au
centre de paris en a une qui sera sur
les chantiers du grand paris et y en a
une qui sera dans la vallée de chevreuse
17 tu es donc c'est une satisfaction
parce que les choses avancent sur ce
front là pour les actions que vous avez
menées en tant que député tout même une
question aussi à vous poser comment se
passe les rapports avec la république en
marche vous qui êtes élu modem
les rapports se passe très bien je suis
secrétaire général du modem donc je suis
amené à discuter de manière quasi
quotidienne avec les responsables
nationaux de la république en marche et
ça se passe très bien dans l'ensemble
et puis avec mes collègues
parlementaires de la république en marge
des yvelines là aussi ça se passe très
bien nous avons commencé à bâtir
ensemble un rendez vous régulier avec
les élus des yvelines qui sont en
soutien de la majorité présidentielle
nous avions reçues jacqueline gourault
il ya quelques mois la semaine dernière
nous avons reçu sébastien lecornu juste
à côté d'ici à elancourt et nous créons
donc des liens d'amitié mais aussi de
réflexion pour pouvoir bâtir ensemble
des projets pour les territoires puisque
c'est ce qui va nous occuper dans les
années qui viennent
et donc on en parle parle maintenant les
municipales les municipales ce sera en
2020 et si je vous ai posé cette
question des rapports avec et lrm aussi
pour le modem c'est parce qu'il va
falloir se mettre d'accord sur des
listes est ce que les discussions sont
déjà engagés et pour être très clair si
l om apporte son soutien à des candidats
républicains voulaient suivait alors
écoutez
comme secrétaire général du modem je
peux observer ce qui se passe au niveau
national et le constat que je fais c'est
que dans l'immense majorité des cas la
république leur marche et le modem de
manière tout à fait naturelle
travaillent ensemble main dans la main
il ya évidemment des cas où on n'est pas
forcément d'accord c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs le cas le plus fréquent c'est
peut-être le cas inverse de celui que
que vous avez mentionné le cas des élus
du modem travaille avec des majorités
sortantes une parfois élèves sont le
plus souvent en tout cas de divers
droite ou centre-droit avec des
réflexions à la république en marche
pour aller ou pour partir ou pour
proposer une alternative à ces majorités
c'est dans ces cas là on essaie de
discuter pour trouver un point
d'atterrissage comme parce que derrière
il y aura des agglomérations à gérer il
faudrait bien dégager des majorités et
voir qui peut se mettre d'accord mais on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler à la
rentrée merci encore d'être venu sur ce
plateau faire un premier bilan vous
ferez une pause pendant l'été bien sûr
en famille merci jean noël barrot nous
allons dans un instant retrouver grégory
canal et en compagnie de gérard larcher
tout de suite un point sur la question
de la décentralisation notions abordées
lors du dernier conseil départemental en
présence du préfet la mise en oeuvre de
la réforme de l'organisation
territoriale de l'état
c'est l'objet de la circulaire du 12
juin envoyée par le premier ministre aux
préfets
elle rappelle notamment c'est à
l'échelon départemental que doivent être
mises en oeuvre les politiques de l'état
une directive rappelé par le préfet des
yvelines lors de son intervention devant
l'assemblée départementale le vendredi
28 juin et illustré avec l'exemple de la
loi sru sur le seuil de logements
sociaux imposé aux communes
notre interprétation sera toujours
positive partir du travail de terrain
et pour mobilisons tous les moyens pour
accompagner dans ce cadre réglementaire
en effet contraignant et que notre
vision des choses sera toujours une
vision bienveillant pour une application
la plus intelligentes et imaginatives de
la loi du côté des institutions
décentralisées conseillers municipaux ou
départementaux maires ou présidents de
départements les attentes sur l'acte de
décentralisation sont importantes alors
je pense qu'il faut donner plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités tout ce que
l'état ne fait pas bien à l'échelon
central il faut le confier aux
collectivités l'état lui doit mieux
faire ce qui est le coeur de son métier
c'est la défense c'est la sécurité
c'est la diplomatie bien entendu et qui
sont aussi des membres de l'unité
nationale mais localement on n'est plus
opérationnel nokia les communes et on
soutient de ces communes il y a les
départements les départements qui
coordonne qui accompagne les communes
leur intercommunalité je dirais de
redonner à la proximité et redonner aux
territoires les compétences et
l'autorité et la responsabilité qu'ils
doivent avoir
qui mieux que les élus de territoire je
dirais sur la proximité sont à même de
mettre en place une réorganisation sur
la réorganisation des services de l'état
dans le département les directives sont
en cours d'application
le gouvernement lancera en 2020 la
réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales
[Musique]
gérard larcher bonjour bonjour alors
c'est ici aujourd'hui vendredi 28 juin à
toussus-le-noble votre troisième visite
sur le territoire des yvelines avec les
sénateurs après saint germain en laye et
versailles pourquoi choisir pour cette
troisième visite toussus le noble
après saint germain en laye versailles
le robot little man toi parce que je
crois qu'on a là l'exemple d'un lieu
d'innovation et de l'innovation qui
dépasse la seule commune de
toussus-le-noble qui s'adresse ailleurs
à tout le pays au travers d'une démarche
vertueuse la réalité l'aéronautique
l'importance de la formation des pilotes
l'importance aussi il faut le dire de ce
que représente l'aviation en matière de
développement économique
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu la volonté
d'une commune d'amer chlorés puisse dire
allez je me débarrasse du dossier et
allez on se bat pour fermer l'aérodrome
il ya eu une démarche qui a été porté
d'abord par une équipe municipale et son
maire et voyez tout ce qu'il nomme je le
dis avec beaucoup de respect c'est pas
une immense métropole
c'est une commune moins de 1500
habitants qui a eu la volonté de prendre
en main son destin dans l'intérêt de ses
habitants en partant d'un principe il
faut dialoguer avec les riverains
parce que c'est vrai qu'à la réalité des
nuisances et en même temps nous sommes à
20 kilomètres de la tour eiffel
on est à cinq kilomètres de la chambre
du roi comme le disait le maire nous
accueillant et patrick charles
il a manifesté avec son équipe
municipale une vraie volonté
il y aussi un sujet je voulais aborder
avec vous gérard larcher c'est la
reconstruction la reconstruction de
votre formation l'est républicain et un
parti qui est en crise après les mauvais
résultats aux élections européennes
alors pour repartir certains plaident
notamment l'union de votre parti avec le
rassemblement national plusieurs élus et
l'air et et collaborateurs ont dîné
récemment avec marion maréchal-le pen
est-ce qu'il faut les exclure du parti
aucune réunion à ce sujet je suis lancé
dans une démarche
nu toute autre nature d'abord je suis
resté dans la famille des républicains
parce que c'est une famille qui doit en
quelque sorte se recomposer c'est à dire
rassembler ce pourquoi elle a été créée
rassemblement des centristes
rassemblement des gaullistes
rassemblement de la famille radicale
rassemblement de la droite libérale
c'est ça notre famille et pour moi il ya
une cloison étanche avec le
rassemblement national
donc c'est même pas un sujet et même en
étant gentil de notre côté avec les
mêmes dîner c'est une brèche dans la
cloison
moi je suis lancé dans une démarche
personnelle mais qui n'est d'abord une
même démarche collective pourquoi
persuade est parce que je me suis dit tu
ne peux pas rester président du sénat
quant au confort et je crois que nous
avons une responsabilité c'est d'occuper
un espace politique qui se situe entre
la république en marche un mouvement
naturellement démocratique et le
rassemblement national dont je ne
considère pas qu'il porte des valeurs
qui me soit qu'ils nous soient
compatibles nous la famille des
républicains et pourquoi parce que nous
l'avons eue est compris dans les
européennes se réduire un choix binaire
entre le président de la république et
madame le pen c'est prendre le risque
politique un matin de nous réveiller
italien voyez à quoi je fais allusion
nos réunions entre les populistes et la
nikon en italien chez nous dire qu'un
jour moddable peine
pourrait être à la tête du pays et pour
moi c'est impensable
et donc je pense que j'ai une
responsabilité mois est bien de dire à
mes compatriotes aux citoyens et pour ça
j'ai une démarche partir du territoire
je pense que notre projet politique
s'est éloigné des réalités territoriales
et d'ailleurs si nous ne repartons pas
au travers de la confiance dans les
territoires au travers des élus au
travers notamment d'une décentralisation
une nouvelle génération de
décentralisation alors nous pourrions
nous réveiller dans une alternative
politique qui ne serait pas conforme
avait valeur
c'est le sens de ma démarche donc le 6
juillet prochain à l'air tient une
convention l'élection du nouveau
président elle doit intervenir à la mi
octobre après le départ de laurent
wauquiez
quel est le travail qui va être opéré la
dent dans les vacances et la
reconstruction vous le disais le 6
juillet devant une convention sur
valeurs et engagements savoir quelles
sont nos valeurs et je prendrai la
parole pour rappeler nos valeurs
y compris à ce qui peut-être ne savent
plus très bien où sont les valeurs
nous sommes un rassemblement nous sommes
de droite et du centre nous sommes golis
pour une partie d'entre nous nous sommes
humaniste nous croyons à la société de
responsabilité de solidarité
nous croyons au territoire c'est tout ça
qu'il faut réaffirmer et puis le moment
venu il y aura le choix d'un président
mais ce qui m'importe moi c'est de
rassembler toutes les familles des
centres et au delà
beaucoup d'élus indépendants pour se
dire ensemble est-ce qu'on partage pas
un même regard sur l'avenir de notre
pays
est ce que ça ne part pas d'abord des
territoires regardez l'exemple de ce
matin à tous il nomme s'il y avait pas
un territoire une commune bien sûr
relayé par un département une région en
lien avec l'êta avec une communauté
d'agglo s'il n'y avait pas une volonté
territoriales je suis pas certain qu'on
en serait là
[Musique]
nous refermons à présent se 7,8
politique prochain numéro à la rentrée
en septembre et l'année prochaine sera
chargée avec les élections municipales
prévues en 2020 d'ici là très bel été
[Musique]